[Musique]
pascal tracts pour un camion neuf
quelques jours après l'achat ils
découvrent des égratignures à plusieurs
endroits un expert en néo bosselage il y
apprend que son camion a été repeint
pascal comme les pires effets sont en
tête
le fabricant du camion lui confirme ce
qu'il redoutait il a été abîmée lors du
grand fort chez le concessionnaire
parce qu'elle n'en revient pas lors de
la vente personne ne lui en a parlé
selon le concessionnaire ce ne sont que
des dommages esthétiques
il n'avait donc aucune obligation de
l'informer de cela mais il tente de
passer un sapin à son client car il
s'agit d'une information décisive si
pascal havet cycle camion a subi des
dommages
il ne leur ai pas achetés et un
commerçant ne peut pas passer sous
silence un fait important
pascal peut donc se tourner vers les
petites créances et demander une
réduction du prix et des dommages
punitifs
le fameux l'histoire quand il est
question refait important
la parole est d'or